[Música]
hola a todos qué tal como todos sabéis
en el año 1928 alexander fleming
descubrió la penicilina como
consecuencia de ese descubrimiento se
han salvado millones de vidas sólo
tenemos que recordar cómo era nuestra
existencia antes del descubrimiento de
los antibióticos cualquier bacteria
patógena podía matarnos o como
consecuencia de una infección por una
bacteria patógena podríamos sufrir una
terrible amputación
las bacterias patógenas diezmaban
poblaciones aniquilaban ejércitos
enteros
por suerte descubrimos los antibióticos
y durante décadas hemos podido combatir
a las bacterias patógenas pero hemos
cometido un error
los hemos utilizado en exceso los hemos
utilizado mal y como consecuencia en
este momento tenemos un problema muy
importante las bacterias les hemos
forzado a que evolucionen a que se
adapten a los antibióticos y tenemos en
este momento a muchas de ellas que son
resistentes a los antibióticos
vamos a empezar un poco por el comienzo
que es un antibiótico un antibiótico no
es más que una sustancia química capaz
de matar a las bacterias o inhibir su
crecimiento
todos sabemos que podemos en este
momento fabricar los antibióticos de
forma sintética pero no debemos olvidar
que los antibióticos han sido fabricados
de forma natural y desde tiempos
inmemoriales por los microorganismos
entre ellos las bacterias si lo pensáis
es paradójico que los mismos organismos
que pueden aniquilar poblaciones enteras
nos han dado la herramienta médica más
poderosa para combatirlos los
antibióticos
y si como os he dicho hemos utilizado
los antibióticos con gran éxito durante
décadas y los hemos utilizado en
medicina los hemos utilizado en
veterinaria y también en agricultura no
olvidemos eso últimamente hay mucho
entre interés en dilucidar el papel
ecológico de los antibióticos en la
naturaleza es decir qué función tienen
los antibióticos cuando las bacterias
los producen en la naturaleza para que
lo hacen inicialmente todos pensamos que
la única el único papel de los
antibióticos de la naturaleza sería el
mismo papel que tienen cuando nosotros
los utilizamos es decir matar las
bacterias en una especie de escenario
bélico en el que en el que las bacterias
en la naturaleza están entre ellas
compitiendo en guerra y utilizan los
antibióticos como armas químicas para
matarse entre ellas
pero lo que hemos descubierto hemos
estudiado otras funciones que tienen los
antibióticos en la naturaleza y una muy
curiosa es que cuando las bacterias
producen los antibióticos a dosis muy
inferiores a las que nosotros utilizamos
con fines terapéuticos los utilizan como
moléculas de señalización química es
decir como moléculas para comunicarse
entre ellas y coordinarse es muy curioso
que dependiendo de la dosis en la
naturaleza las bacterias utilizan los
antibióticos para matarse entre ellas o
utilizan los antibióticos para
coordinarse comunicarse y coordinar
como os he dicho al comienzo no hay que
engañar a nadie tenemos un programa muy
importante hemos utilizado los
antibióticos en exceso los hemos
utilizado de forma inadecuada y hemos
forzado a las bacterias a que se adapten
a que evolucionen son seres con una
terrible capacidad de adaptación y
resiliencia y a través de mutaciones en
sus genes de estas mutaciones en su
material genético han aprendido a
hacerse resistentes a los antibióticos y
tenemos algunas cepas bacterianas
resistentes a todos los antibióticos
pero no sólo se pueden hacer resistentes
a los antibióticos tienen la capacidad
de pasar los genes que les confieren esa
resistencia a sus bacterias
descendientes o también tienen la
capacidad de marcón de pasar esos genes
de resistencia a bacterias que no son
sus descendientes es decir se pueden
hacer resistentes a los antibióticos y
pueden diseminar la resistencia a los
antibióticos
y este es un programa muy importante hay
gente bueno bastante gente y piensa que
es un problema menor que de vez en
cuando de forma ocasional alguna persona
es infectada por una bacteria patógena
resistente a los antibióticos todo lo
contrario
en este momento mueren más de 700.000
personas al año como consecuencia de
infecciones causadas por bacterias
patógenas resistentes a los antibióticos
eso nos da una medida de 80 personas a
la hora y por supuesto el número de
personas infectadas por estas bacterias
resistentes es mucho mayor pero como
consecuencia de los avances en la
medicina por suerte se salvan se estima
que si las cosas siguen así para el año
2050 en vez de 700.000 personas morirán
10 millones de personas al año como
consecuencia de este problema
superando entonces el impacto que tiene
el cáncer en otro orden de cosas el
banco mundial advierte que si no hacemos
nada en el año 2050 este problema de las
bacterias resistentes a los antibióticos
podrá causar una recesión económica
global similar a la del año 2008
en este momento nos surge a todos la
pregunta evidente que podemos hacer los
ciudadanos
y la respuesta es muy fácil por el
momento hacer caso a los médicos qué
quiere decir eso usar los antibióticos
solo cuando ellos no los receten usar
los antibióticos como ellos nos digan
que tenemos que utilizarlos y por encima
de todo sobre todo por favor no
presionarlos para que nos recetan
antibióticos
pero por desgracia eso no lo hace no va
a ser suficiente las bacterias
resistentes a los antibióticos ya están
en nuestro entorno las bacterias son
series muy resilientes por increíbles
capacidades de adaptación y como todo
ser vivo su principal objetivo es hacer
copias de sí mismo no va a ser fácil
eliminar el problema por eso los
científicos estamos investigando
diferentes diferencias posibilidades las
hará más evidentes para racionalizar el
uso de los antibióticos vamos a hacer
hacer un uso más racional de los
antibióticos así podemos reducir la
cantidad de antibióticos que utilizamos
y aunque no consigamos eliminar el
problema por lo menos impediremos o
ralentizar hemos el crecimiento de este
problema
una línea de investigación que no tiene
demasiados recursos en los que
tendríamos que poner más recursos es la
búsqueda de nuevos antibióticos y donde
podemos encontrar nuevos antibióticos
pues entre las bacterias que en el suelo
fijaos en un solo gramo de suelo lo que
me cabe en una cucharita de café en un
grano de suelo hay billones de bacterias
pertenecientes a miles de especies
diferentes y tenemos mucho suelo a
nuestro alrededor
seguro que entre las millones de
especies de bacterias que habitan en los
suelos de nuestros bosques de nuestros
jardines y parques de nuestros pastos
podemos encontrar nuevos antibióticos
pero hay un hecho incuestionable si
cuando los encontremos los utilizamos en
exceso y los utilizamos mal las
bacterias serán resistentes también a
esos nuevos antibióticos
por eso estamos buscando otras
alternativas para matar a las bacterias
que las bacterias patógenas por supuesto
que no sean los antibióticos y en esta
línea de investigación se trabaja mucho
en virus
llegamos virus mata bacterias que se
llaman fagos bacteriófagos que son virus
que al igual que los antibióticos tienen
la capacidad de matar a las bacterias
pero una vez más las bacterias son seres
muy resilientes y tiene la habilidad de
hacerse resistentes también estos virus
por eso una línea de investigación muy
interesante es buscar compuestos
químicos que inhiban la conjugación
bacteriana la conjugación bacteriana es
el principal mecanismo que utilizan las
bacterias para pasarse los genes de
resistencia de unas a otras
entonces si conseguimos inhibir este
mecanismo esta conjugación bacteriana
por lo menos impediremos la
discriminación de los genes de
resistencia entre las comunidades de las
bacteria
pero mirar el principal la principal
idea o el principal mensaje que me
gustaría lanzar o soy es que si queremos
solucionar el problema de las
resistencias a los antibióticos de las
bacterias patógenas resistentes a los
antibióticos tenemos que recorrer un
camino un camino que es largo complejo
tortuoso pero a la vez es un camino
apasionante extraordinario que es el
camino de la ecología microbiana que
quiero decir es el camino que nos lleva
a la comprensión de cómo viven las
bacterias en su entorno cómo
interaccionan entre ellas cómo
interaccionan con otros organismos cómo
interaccionan con su medio tenemos que
recorrer este camino y al final de este
camino vamos a descubrir la estructura
biológica la obra de arquitectura
biológica más alucinante que en este
planeta que es una red de
microorganismos que ha colonizado una
red de microorganismos y bacterias que
ha colonizado todo este planeta
para empezar a recorrer este camino
tenemos que asumir de una vez por todas
que las bacterias no son seres aislados
que viven aislados la mayor parte de las
bacterias no viven aisladas en fase
libre nadando flotando en un medio
acuoso no las bacterias viven en
comunidades
son seres sociales que les gusta vivir
en ciudades viven en comunidades
altamente complejas espacialmente
estructuradas de hecho la mayor parte de
las bacterias en la naturaleza vive en
lo que se llama biofilms o biopelículas
que no son más que comunidades de
microorganismos que viven adheridas a
una superficie y están embebidas en una
matriz gelatinosa que ellas mismas han
sintetizado
pero esto porque es importante el camino
este de ver cómo se relacionan entre
ellas las bacterias y cómo cómo viven en
comunidades en ciudades en una charla
sobre resistencia a los antibióticos
porque dependiendo de si están en fase
libre aisladas o si están como la
mayoría de ellas viviendo agrupadas en
comunidades su comportamiento
radicalmente diferente su metabolismo es
diferente su genética es diferente y los
investigadores los científicos por
inercia y facilidad seguimos estudiando
las cepas bacterianas en los medios de
cultivo aisladas y su comportamiento
real no es ese si queremos combatir a
las bacterias patógenas o si queremos
aprender de las bacterias no patógenas
que son la mayor parte de ellas
tenemos que superar un poco los enfoques
y la metodología de la microbiología
convencional y mezclar la microbiología
con la ecología y pensar en términos de
ecología microbiana y mezclar la
sociología con la microbiología y pensar
como socio microbiólogos porque los
microorganismos viven viven en
comunidades en consorcios
y en este camino vamos a descubrir como
os he dicho la obra de arquitectura
biológica más asombrosa que en este
planeta hace casi cuatro mil millones de
años las bacterias empezaron en este
planeta a colonizar lo llevan cuatro
casi cuatro mil millones de años
colonizando ya le encontramos bacterias
a billones en todos los rincones de este
planeta
encontramos bacterias a billones en los
suelos encontramos bacterias a billones
en los océanos en los sedimentos marinos
en los ríos en el aire en esta sala en
el interior y en la superficie de las
plantas en el interior de la superficie
de los suns de los animales incluidos
los humanos somos nodos de esa red de
esa red que se empezó a formar hace
cuatro mil millones de años somos nodos
estamos ya habréis oído que más del 50
por ciento de las células que habitan en
nuestro cuerpo no son células humanas
son bacterias microorganismos con los
que vivimos en simbiosis y tenemos
bacterias a billones en el intestino en
la boca en las fosas nasales en la piel
estamos literalmente cubiertos de
microorganismos y son muy importantes
para nuestra salud en parte nuestra
salud depende del estado óptimo del
equilibrio ecológico de esas comunidades
bacterianas con las que vivimos en
simbiosis pero cuál es la lección más
importante que podemos aprender de esta
obra maravillosa de arquitectura
biológica que es esa red que ha
colonizado todo el planeta la lección
más importante que podemos aprender es
como vivir sostenible mente se empezó a
formar hace casi cuatro mil millones de
años no sé mi turno se me ocurrió mejor
ejemplo de sostenibilidad la historia de
esa red de cómo se ha formado es la
historia del planeta tierra
y si no hay que engañar a nadie no somos
niños el problema de la resistencia a
los antibióticos es un problema muy
importante es uno de los retos
principales del siglo 21 comparable sin
ninguna duda al reto del cambio
climático y tenemos que meter recursos
investigación y todos colaborar por no
seguir discriminando este problema pero
también es una razón muy poderosa una
oportunidad increíble para recorrer este
camino y entender cómo viven los
microorganismos en su entorno y entender
mejor a las bacterias y con suerte
podremos aprender a ser tan resistentes
tan resilientes tan sostenibles tener
las increíbles capacidades de adaptación
su increíble versatilidad metabólica su
increíble plasticidad genética podremos
aprender mucho de ellas yo ya me voy
haciendo mayor ya estoy cercano a los 60
me voy haciendo mayor pero cada vez
deseo con más fuerza que jóvenes
investigadores brillantes se incorporen
a este camino de la comprensión de la
ecología de los microorganismos y por
supuesto su espero
que todos los que estamos aquí podamos
ver en dónde acaba este camino
[Aplausos]